Islam's most trusted sources are filled
with claims about Muhammad's amazing
verility and sexual stamina. Muhammad
was famous among his followers for being
able to handle nine or even 11 women and
girls in a single night. Consider a few
passages. Sah Bkari 5068
narrated anus. The prophet used to go
around have sexual relations with all
his wives in one night and he had nine
wives.
Sahil Bkari 52:15
narrated Anusban Malik the prophet used
to pass by have sexual relation with all
his wives in one night and at that time
he had nine wives. By the way, check out
the chapter heading. Whoever had sexual
intercourse in the boiling, sweaty
Arabian desert with all his wives and
then took one bath only.
Brother,
try not to imagine the smell by the time
he climbed on top of wife number nine.
Sahib Bukari 268
narrated Kata Anus bin Malik said the
prophet used to visit all his wives in
around during the day and night and they
were 11 in number. I asked Anus had the
prophet the strength for it. Anus
replied, "We used to say that the
prophet was given the strength of 30
men." And Zahed said on the authority of
Kata that Anus had told him about nine
wives only, not 11.
Muhammad's followers used to say that he
was given the strength, the sexual
strength of 30 men.
That's an oddly specific number, isn't
it? The prophet was given the strength
of 30 men.
An average man has no problem having sex
with his wife some night. If a healthy
man had two or three wives, I don't see
why he couldn't have sex with two or
three wives in a single evening. So why
didn't Muhammad's followers say that he
was given the strength of three or four
men? Why 30 specifically?
Fortunately for us, modern historical
and anthropological researchers have
solved this mystery. We now know how
Muhammad received the strength of 30,
count them, 30 men. Inspiring Philosophy
sent me so many studies on this topic,
I'd need the strength of 30 men just to
share the highlights with you. But
there's one study from psychologist
Bruce Rin that provides quite the
overview. So, I'll quote a few relevant
excerpts. Let me go ahead and say as we
begin, you have no clue how common
relationships between grown men and
adolescent boys were in the ancient and
medieval periods. You may have heard
some things about ancient Greece, but
this was all over the place. Africa, the
Middle East, Southeast Asia, the
Americas,
everyone seemed to have something going
on with adolescent boys. Even after the
spread of Islam, for instance, this
continued for centuries in the Muslim
world. Mature immature male homosexual
behavior was pervasive in Islamic
societies, North Africa, Western Central
Asia from 8th to 19th centuries. Mature
immature male homosexual attractions
were seen as just as normal as
heterosexual ones. Main interest was in
boys early to mid- teens, peaking at
about 14. The appeal vanished with a
beard about 161 17. Adult men were
scorned if they were passive partners.
Manly behavior was to be active.
Partners gender did not matter.
Staggering amounts of love poetry show
an obsession with boyish beauty seen as
comparable to women's. Poets attracted
to boys constitute a who's who. Desire
for boys but not behavior or lust was
permissible under Islam. But behavior
was common nevertheless.
This shouldn't be surprising since the
Quran repeatedly entices Muslim men with
the youths of paradise. Surah 52.
Therein they shall pass to one another a
cup wherein is no idol talk nor
incitement to sin and there wait upon
them youss for them as if they were
hidden pearls. Surah 56 immortal youths
wait upon them with goblets. Surah 76
immortal youths wait upon them. When
thou seeest them thou would think them
scattered pearls.
Way to get the troops fantasizing,
Muhammad.
Here's a description of the practice in
Libya.
Mature, immature, male homosexual
behavior was a well- entrenched custom
from antiquity to at least the 1950s.
Matchmakers made marriage-like
arrangements between men and adolescent
boys. The boy got a gift larger than
bride prices for females. Man and boy
then entered into an alliance with
family approval. Prominent men lent each
other their sons for sex. Love affairs
and jealousies over boys were common.
Robin mom said they will kill for a boy,
never for a woman. Again, this was all
over the place. But we know a bit more
about how some ancient cultures in
Melanesia and New Guinea, for instance,
thought these relationships played an
extremely important role in the
development of boys into men. Mature
immature male homosexual behavior was
highly organized in this warrior
society. Homosexual intercourse was
believed essential to boys physical and
spiritual development. It supposedly
transferred male power to them,
implanting this in their penises, the
seat of male power. The belief was that
insemination grew the boys into men. At
11 or 12, a boy's father chose for him
an older male to inseminate him for
months or years. Some boys chose their
own inseminator. Insemination was
thought essential for growth. Between
ages 10 and 14, boys entered a men's
house after a ceremony declaring them
deceased, i.e. death of childhood. They
were newly born through the powerful
medicine of older males semen. Each boy
acquired an adoptive father, an older
male who was his mentor and regularly
inseminated him, which was believed
necessary to make him strong.
Males lived in sex segregated men's
houses from a young age. Mature immature
male homosexual activity was pervasive.
A certain kind of insemination was seen
as crucial for boys development. It
began in male initiations for boys
ranging in age from 7 to 14. Seaman was
viewed necessary for growth to be a
strong warrior.
So they believed that verility and
manliness could be injected into a boy
by a man.
There were some very strange very
disturbing ideas circulating in the
ancient world and in the 7th century
cultures were interacting and colliding
because of trade. Muhammad before he
declared himself a prophet of Allah was
a caravan trader. He spent years having
discussions with various people he met
and he had a tendency to believe what
people told him. Even much later, long
after he started preaching Islam, he was
known as the ear. It's in the Quran.
Surah 9:61.
And among them are those who torment the
prophet and say he is an ear.
What did they mean when they called him
an ear? Ibn Assat gives the historical
background.
I have heard that it was of him, a man
named Nabtal, that the apostle said,
"Whoever wants to see Satan, let him
take a look at Nabtal Iban Al-Harath. He
was a sturdy black man with long flowing
hair, inflamed eyes, and dark, ruddy
cheeks." Pretty racist to say this black
man looked like Satan. He used to come
and talk to the apostle and listen to
him and then carry what he had said to
the hypocrites. It was he who said
Muhammad is all ears. If anyone tells
him anything, he believes it. And we
have some commentary in the study Quran.
He is an ear is an idiomatic expression
used as an insult to imply that the
prophet was easily swayed by what he
heard and had no resolve. Being called
an ear, all Razi explains, is like
calling a spy an eye. The accusation was
that the prophet was gullible, accepting
whatever he heard. According to some,
there were those around the prophet who
said, "We say what we wish, then we
swear to him, and he believes us."
So, Muhammad was known for being
gullible and believing whatever people
told him. This explains why he spread so
many silly claims. He said that Adam was
90 ft tall, 60 cubits. He said that if a
fly falls into your drink, you should
dunk the fly in the drink because one of
the wings has a disease, but the other
wing has the cure for the disease. He
told his followers to drink camel urine
as medicine. This stuff is endless in
the Muslim sources. Where did this
nonsense come from?
Muhammad apparently just believed
whatever people told him, so they called
him the ear.
But Muhammad had an interesting way of
taking practices that were geared
towards children and applying them to
adults.
For example, in Muhammad's time, people
thought that if a woman breastfeeds a
child she's not related to, the child
becomes related to her. The breast milk
makes the child a relative. Muhammad
shocked his followers by claiming that
this works even with a grown man. A
grown man can absorb a woman's breast
milk and become her son. Sunnisai 33:21.
This is the chapter of breastfeeding an
adult. And we read Zanab bent Abi Salma
said I heard Aisha the wife of the
prophet says Saha bent Su a woman came
to the messenger of Allah and said oh
messenger of Allah I see displeasure in
the face of Abu Hudifa her husband when
Sull enters upon me. Salom was a grown
man. Her husband Abu Hudhifa didn't like
a grown man being around his wife
because he was worried that they might
commit adultery.
The messenger of Allah said breastfeed
him. She said he has a beard. He said
breastfeed him and that will take away
the displeasure in the face of Abu
Hudhifa. She said by Allah I never saw
that on the face of Abu Hudhifa. After
that,
she breastfed a grown man with a beard,
and this made the man her son. So, her
husband was no longer worried about his
wife committing adultery with the young
man because she had put her breasts in
the young man's mouth. By absorbing her
breast milk, he was transformed into her
son.
What else can a grown man absorb?
Imagine
a man who's known as the ear hearing
about men injecting their manliness and
verility into boys. Keep in mind this
man believes that practices that people
usually apply to children also work with
adults as with breastfeeding.
Suppose this man wants to become the
most viral, masculine, potent man on the
planet.
How would he go about that?
He would assemble a team of men known
for their sexual prowess. And in
Muhammad's time, the men who were most
famous for their sexual prowess were the
men of Alz. Historian Raymond Ibrahim
explains how alz are described in the
Muslim sources. According to Islam's
written records, they were a migrant
people from India or modern-day
Pakistan. described in the sources as
very tall, very dark-skinned, very lean,
strong and hearty and often used for
labor intensive work. In early Arabic
ethnographies and literary works, al zut
are also depicted as being very sexual
and veriral with very large penises. In
fact, according to one Arabic source by
quote, the penis of alz never weakens,
meaning their large fallacuses never go
limp and are ever ready. I'm sorry for
the coup language, but this is what the
Islamic texts say verbatim. Could the
men of Alz transfer their verility and
manliness into Muhammad? Let's find out
by reading a now infamous hadith from
Musnid Ahmed. Abdullah ibn Masud
related, the messenger of Allah sent for
me. So he set out until I reached such
and such a place. And he traced a line
for me and told me, "Stay between the
two edges of this. Don't go outside of
it. If you go outside of it, it's over
for you." Muhammad knew that Abdullah
wasn't man enough to endure the men of
Al.
Abdullah said, "And so I stayed there."
Then the messenger of Allah went off a
stones throw away or a little farther or
something like that. Then he Abdullah
mentioned a group of male members hanin
i.e. men who looked like zut people.
Afan narrated or something like what
Afan said Allah willing. They didn't
have any clothes on. You don't say. And
I didn't see their genitals and they
were tall and scrawny. He Abdullah said,
"And they came and started to ride the
messenger of Allah. And the prophet of
Allah began to recite to them, and they
started to move closer and lean around
me and get in my way, and I became
intensely terrified of them. So I sat
down or something like that." He sat
down, thus protecting the part of him
they were after. And when the morning
light broke, they began to go away or
something like that. Then the messenger
of Allah came back exhausted and in pain
I'll bet or practically in pain from how
they had ridden him. He said indeed I am
exhausted or something like that. Then
the messenger of Allah put his head in
my lap or something like that. And the
men came with tall white garments on but
the messenger of Allah had fallen
asleep. and I became more intensely
terrified of them than I was the first
time. The men of Alz rode Muhammad all
night long. From then on, his followers
could boast that he was given the
strength of 30 men.
30 men of al- Zut gathered in the desert
and injected their masculinity into the
prophet of Islam, making him the most
powerful man in the world. Of course,
the effects might wear off after a
while. Sometimes Muhammad would need to
top off the tank, so to speak. That's
when his companion Deha al- Kalbi would
come to the rescue. As Muhammad's
companion, Hudifa said, the people used
to enter upon the prophet whenever they
wanted. The prophet then prohibited them
from entering upon him while he was in
meeting with Datal Caldi.
Muhammad didn't want anyone disturbing
him when he was in one of his private
meetings with Dhel Kalby, who by the way
was the hottest young stud in all of
Arabia.
Hudifa continues, "One day I came to the
prophet for some matter, hoping to meet
him alone. When I arrived at the door, I
looked and found a curtain covering the
door. I raised it and was about to
enter. That's what we are accustomed to
do." Then I saw Deha sitting beside the
prophet who was sleeping and his head
was on the lap of Dha. When I saw that I
left.
What did Muhammad do after his rough
night with the men of Alz? He put his
head on Abdullah's lap and passed out.
What did he do after a meeting with Dha
Alcali?
He put his head on Dehi's lap and passed
out.
Later, Muhammad told his followers that
when they see him with Dei Alcali, it's
actually the angel Gabriel.
Sure, it's the angel Gabriel,
conveniently disguised as Dea Alcali.
And Dea was always sure to leave his
calling card. Sahil Bukari 232
narrated Aisha. I used to wash the semen
off the clothes of the prophet and even
then I used to notice one or more spots
on them. Aisha would wash the semen off
his clothes. She would scratch it from
his garment. She would scrape it off
with her hand.
Small price to pay for having such a
manly husband though, am I right?
So we finally understand how Muhammad
got the strength of 30 men. He told an
elite squad of 30 men of Alz known for
their large penises to meet him in the
desert. He told his companion Abdullah
to watch and learn from behind the diddy
line. He walked about a stones throw
away and assumed the position. Then the
alzut showed up and said, "It's zutin
time." and zooted all over him all night
long. But this gave Muhammad the stamina
to have sex with nine or 11 women and
girls in a single night. So win-win, I
guess, except for the one bath part.
>> What's that?
What's that, brother?
>> Now we've solved one mystery, but
another mystery remains.
If relationships between men and
adolescent boys were so common in the
ancient world, as numerous studies have
shown, why are they so surprising and
disturbing to us now? What changed?
The good news is that we know exactly
what changed, but you'll have to click
on Inspiring Philosophies video to find
out.
[Music]